this video is brought to you by
Squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business at the squarespace.com
for a free trial and when you're ready
to go for launch
go to squarespace.com /by graphics to
save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or a domain now it's likely
you've really heard of Coco Chanel
either from her famous perfume or the
luxury clothing brands based on her name
as a woman trying to build a business in
a time where the world was controlled by
men Chanel started at less than zero
then yet she found a way to climb to the
position of being one of the most
wealthy and powerful women in the world
on today is by graphics we're here to
tell you the true rags to riches story
of Coco Chanel Gabrielle Chanel was born
on August the 19th 1883 in France's
Loire Valley her mother
Eugenie Jean Duval was an unwed laundry
woman she gave birth to Gabrielle in a
Charity Hospital run by nuns on the day
she was born her mother had to ride
traveling where the father's name should
be that wasn't just an excuse for an
absentee dad though because Albert
Chanel traveled from town to town
selling clothes to local peasants
Gabrielle had one older sister Julia and
they were less than a year apart the
couple had their hands full with two
infant daughters and they could hardly
scrape by with what little money they
had in 1884 Albert and Zhang Fei gave
them money so that they could pay for a
marriage license after that Union was
official they had several more children
and the family all lived in a cramped
one-room apartment in the town of breve
like AR de Gabrielle learns out a sir at
an early age to help her father with his
clothing business but when she was just
12 years old Gabrielle's mother came
sick and died raising young children is
very much a full-time job and he could
not earn an income and take care of them
at the same time he sent his sons to
work on a farm and the girls were sent
to a convent to be raised by nuns the
nuns taught her discipline as well as
how to read and write she learned to
carry herself with the Grace and the
elegance of a lady rather
than a peasant most of the other
children living in the convent they were
orphans but since her father was still
alive Gabrielle refused to consider
herself an orphan too she held on to the
hope that her father would return one
day and that they could be a family
again at this time in our life books
acted as a way for her to get lost
in a world of fantasy she began to
create elaborate stories about her own
life as well to help ease the pain of
her reality later in life one of the
most common stories she told her friends
was how she was raised by her strict
aunties she continued to tell lies and
half-truths about her past which made it
almost impossible for anyone to know
just how difficult her childhood truly
had been at age 18 Gabrielle left the
convent to find a job there were very
few opportunities for women to find work
but she was lucky to have sewing skills
that should learned from her father she
won't as a seamstress during the day
making clothing for the rich ladies in
the town of Milan this was a very
solitary job and she was hidden in a
back room working long hours mending and
assembling garments at night she worked
a second job as a nightclub where she
would sing and dance in front of a crowd
when she was 23 her act caught the
attention of a man named Etienne balsa
he was the heir to the wealthy balisong
garment company which supplied the
French army with its uniforms Gabrielle
Chanel started going by the nickname
Coco years later or even Chanel herself
would tell a different story of where
the name came from some believe that was
based on the lyrics of a song she used
to sing others think it's short for the
French Coco which means a kept woman or
in today's slang a sugar baby for
someone in Gabrielle Chanel situation
these wealthy men were the only hope she
had of escaping poverty while saw had a
type which was aspiring actresses the
girlfriends who lived with him before
Chanel was named Emily or darling Coe
and she went on to become rich and
famous with her successful career in
Paris Gabrielle had no illusions about
the relationship that she had with etiam
bow saw and she knew that by sleeping
with him he could introduce her to the
right people this after a few auditions
it was clear that she just wasn't cut
out for show business she was staying as
balsams house in the country the chateau
de royal Oh for a few days though were
sets in the middle of the forest where
balsa enjoyed riding
horses and hunting when his guests came
over the weekend he kept her like his
dirty little secret
telling her to hide in one of the back
bedrooms this was infuriating for Chanel
it was clear the ball son was willing to
sleep with her but he was ashamed to be
seen with her in public
plenty of people would feel completely
dejected by this whole situation but
instead of feeling defeated
this sparked a fire in her she wanted to
prove that she was worthy of being at
this party the only problem was that the
clothes she arrived in midges rather
obvious that she was poor so she took
one of bosshoss suits and cut it apart
tailoring it to fit her body perfectly
then she showed up to the party
uninvited she carried herself with
confidence while everyone's heads turned
to see this beautiful woman standing in
a man suit when the guests asked why she
was dressed like that she casually said
that it was far more comfortable
remember this happened in the year 1906
so this was completely unheard of women
were wearing corsets long gloves and
multiple layers of skirts at this party
Chanel was clever and interesting to
talk to when she made new friends she
would make out elaborate stories about
her past just like she had done as a
young girl she once said my life didn't
please me so I created my life but salt
was impressed by the stunts so he
allowed her to continue living at his
chateau and she joined his in a circle
of friends he began to treat her to new
clothes and jewelry but she continued to
use the fabric from Belson's discarded
clothing to make herself outfits to wear
instead for most women madding layers of
fabric feathers and jewels was a way to
show off that they were married to
someone who had a lot of money Chanel
thought these things were rather vulgar
and she didn't care if a simple style
made her look poor she just wanted to be
comfortable soon enough other women
began to copy Coco style looking at
photos of Chanel in a youth it's almost
as if they were taken today or like if
she was a time traveler sent back a
hundred years years later she was quoted
as saying in order to be irreplaceable
one must be different during World War
one women everywhere began to wear pants
because they had to work while their
husbands were away but by the time the
men married they wanted their wives to
go back to wearing dresses of course
women in the art class never had to work
at all so they never stopped wearing
their corsets and their layers of
uncomfortable fabric if Coco Chanel was
going to convince them to change it
would happen in stages
over a very long period of time
[Music]
when she was 26 years old Gabrielle
Mezen English businessman named Arthur
Kapil is one of 80 on bel sauce parties
everyone called him boy because he was
the illegitimate son of an heiress to
Kratt he worked his way up in the world
to become a self-made man out of
everyone in Belson's inner circle he was
one of the only people who actually
worked for a living
shell was not satisfied to sit around
and do nothing all day like other kept
women she was earning an income from
selling custom-made hats to women who
admired her style but she kept the money
in cash at the time women could not own
businesses rents and apartments or even
have bank accounts without a guarantor
which was usually the father or the
husband Arthur Kapil would see that
Gabrielle Chanel was a genius and he
believed in her long before anyone else
did he encouraged her to open a shop and
he helps her by putting his name on
everything
Gabrielle ran the business entirely on
her own and began hiring women's who
increase production boy and Coco were a
perfect pair because they were both
passionate about each of that respective
businesses and had a mutual respect for
one another
Arthur Kapil used his experience to help
look over contracts and negotiate the
business deals but the rest was all on
her even before opening her first shop
Chanel already had lawyer clientele from
Paris so it became successful right out
of the gate and she began seeing profits
almost immediately
boy and Coco used the money to purchase
a lavish townhouse in Paris which
doubled as a fashion studio the whole of
the ground-floor was an open space
filled with a workshop she created jobs
for women in the local area and a staff
was growing all the time upstairs she
kept in apartment and whenever Kapil was
in Paris he lived with her there but no
matter what she did to prove her success
Coco Chanel could never be seen as the
marrying type in the eyes of the
aristocracy as a member of a noble
family
Arthur Kapil was expected to end his
affair and marry someone with a title in
1918 he weds an English woman named
Diana Wyndham who was a widow and
related to an assortment of L's dukes
but he and Chanel they were still very
much in love and continued their
relationship behind closed doors on the
22nd of December 1919 Arthur Capel died
in a car crash on his way to spend the
holidays with Coco his funeral was on
Christmas Eve they were together for
nine years and Chanel planned to live
out the rest of her
life with him she was just 35 years old
when he died Arthur Kapil been the love
of her life and no other man ever came
close to replacing him years later her
name would be known around the world and
those same era Stoke rats who refused to
accept her would be fighting to wear her
designs became a point in her life when
her celebrity catapulted her to a place
where she could have married anyone she
wanted but she never did
the one man she wanted to be her husband
was gone forever he knew her before
during and after her success and there
was no way to replace that but she had a
resilience that helped her to keep going
no matter what she said when you're
feeling sad add more lipstick and attack
okay okay so just before you get into
fashion and war and Nazis let me take a
moment to tell you about Squarespace who
make videos like this possible
Squarespace empowers dreamers makers and
doers it gives them tools to bring their
creative ideas to life
Squarespace also makes this very easy
they've got this all-in-one platform so
you can just claim a domain build a
website and even if you want to you can
sell online there's no fussing around
with getting a domain from you know one
website buying that transferring it over
to Squarespace and then working out how
to sell something or whatever it's all
neat and tidy on Squarespace all in one
place very nice plus it's not gonna look
too shabby either and by not too shabby
I mean it's gonna look fantastic
they've got award-winning templates a
perfect starting point then what you do
is you customize them to your heart's
content much like Coco Chanel and those
suits
plus there's 24/7 customer support chat
and email and they've got loads of
accessible and not confusing
documentation on how to make your
website plus email marketing allows you
to keep in touch with your fans or your
customers Squarespace it makes it easy
get that domain get that site dot get a
shop up and running if you want to easy
go to Squarespace come for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch
get the Squarespace calm /bi graphics
and save 10% off your first purchase of
a website or a domain and let's get back
to Coco Chanel
after the unexpected death of her
beloved boy Coco Chanel needed to find a
new business partner at that time she
had over 300 employees she was designing
couture dresses that was selling for
over 3,000 francs each in today's money
there's more like 38 thousand dollars
per dress she had an entire army of
women making these things you would
think that this should have proven that
she was more than capable of running a
successful business but well no she was
still a woman so the bank's refused to
deal directly with her it would become
impossible for her to run a business on
cash alone and it was completely
necessary for her to seek help from a
new male partner the law banning women
from opening bank accounts it would not
change until 1965 after the passing of
the French family law this is when she
met Pierre veux Tamir he had a
reputation for working together with
other luxury brands around Paris and the
offered to become her business partner
the only issue was that Chanel knew
nothing about law or business contracts
Arthur Kapil had always had a best
interest at heart and he gave her the
freedom to run her business as she
pleased and keep the profits for herself
so she was too trusting and she
unwittingly signed a contract that said
Pierre Berton Mayer was entitled to take
90% of her business profits
even though this contractor was
ridiculously unfair is meant that Chanel
could stand business and she did not let
this setback get the best of her
in 1921 Chanel began working with a
celebrity perfume chemist named Ernest
beau at the time women were wearing oils
that had a single floral scent she
wanted to create a perfume with the
layers which developed over time this is
when they created Chanel number five and
it became one of the best-selling
perfumes in the world for years to come
perfume and candle makers would copy the
idea of mixing various scents together
to create a unique experience before
Chanel women never wore black unless
they were in mourning in the 1920s vogue
competitor iconic little black dress to
Ford's model-t it was simple elegance
and revolutionary soon enough people
around the world were looking to Chanel
for inspiration there was a ripple
effect in women's clothing in the rest
of the world without Coco Chanel there
is no telling what kinds of clothes
women would be wearing today
years later she now reflected on that
time saying I gave women a sense of
freedom I gave them back their bodies
bodies that were drenched in sweat
due to fashions finery lace courses
under clothes padding despite the fact
that she swore off ever marrying Chanel
continued to be in relationships with
men but no matter how powerful they may
have been she always to stay true to
herself she dated Grand Duke Dmitry
Pavlovich who was related to the Russian
Romanov family next was Edward the 8th
Prince of Wales and before the dawn of
World War two she began a relationship
with a German man named Baron Hans
Gunther von Dinklage looking at her
track record it would seem that she had
a personal goal of trying to see if she
could date at least one aristocrat from
every country in Europe but our decision
to be in a relationship with von
Dinklage would become both a blessing
and a curse just a few years later the
Nazi Party would rise to power and
Chanel's lover would reveal his true
colours
[Music]
by the 1930s business was absolutely
booming and they needed all the space
they could get in the house of Chanel
her all-female staff increased in
numbers and it became necessary for
Chanel to move out of the studio and
into the Hotel Ritz which was directly
across the street from her business in
1936 there was a labor movement in
France and workers were demanding better
conditions across the country on the
26th of April Coco Chanel arrived at a
studio to see that all of her employees
were sitting on the foreign protest they
all refused to work unless their wages
were increased and their work hours for
lessons chanel was outraged because she
already paid these women higher wages
and gave more vacation time than any
other business instead of giving in to
their demands she fired every single one
of them on the spot
saying that they were in grateful and
that she could do the work on her own
but they refused to move finally she
gave in to their demands for the sake of
getting on with the work now in 1939
Germany had occupied Poland and Chanel
knew that it was only a matter of time
before they were coming for France it's
possible that her boyfriends from
dinkledge let her know that the takeover
was imminent she laid off all 300 of our
workers and encouraged them to seek
safety before it was too late
Coco Chanel she was not going to leave
her business though no matter what
happened just three months later Germany
occupied France the Nazis destroyed the
businesses and the homes of countless
numbers of French people
the Nazis even took over the Hotel Ritz
as their headquarters so Chanel very
literally had to live among them her
home and her business were both safe so
long as she continued that relationship
with one dinkledge
but knowing Chanel she would have hated
this she never wanted to be beholden to
any men let alone the ones who thought
they could rule the world
the Nazis knew that she was close
friends with the British royal family so
they asked if she would become one of
their secret agents in 1943 she was
given the codename model hat on a trip
with von dinkenstein at with Winston
Churchill and handed him a letter which
gave Germany's demands for England's
surrender obviously he didn't take the
offer and it wouldn't be surprising if
he crumpled up the paper where he stood
there is no way of knowing what was said
between Churchill and Chanel was she
actually double agent divulging Nazi
secrets we will never know but when the
war was over Chanel was never brought to
trial for cooperating with the Nazis
she never spoke about that time and
buried it deep like she did with all of
the other unpleasant memories and
life Coco Chanel never said anything
publicly that was anti-semitic the only
documented issue she ever had was with
Pierre vert Amer who just so happens to
be Jewish
after the Nazis occupied France they
were seizing any property that belonged
to the Jews and that included businesses
she wrote a letter to the Nazi
government asking if there was a chance
that she could buy back the remaining
90% of house Chanel however the family
temporarily sold their business entities
to Christians during the war and that
already fled to safety there are plenty
of people who cannot forgive Coco Chanel
for cooperating with the Nazis but for a
moment just put yourself in her shoes
she had two choices break up with her
boyfriend condemn the Nazis and lose
everything or bite her tongue and keep
on pretending for the benefit of
maintaining the life that she had worked
so hard to build she chose her life and
if she were alive today she probably
wouldn't even bother to explain her
decisions in her own words I don't care
what you think of me and I think about
you at all when the war was over in 1945
Chanel dumped von Dinklage quicker than
you can say auf wiedersehen she then
moved on to having an affair with the
Spanish artist Salvador Dali which is an
interesting choice to say the least
[Music]
when the war was over in 1945 Coco
Chanel was 62 years old and she no
longer felt inspired to create new
clothes
she chose to retire from the fashion
world for years and lived off the
royalties from the sales of her perfume
in 1958 she found her second wind at the
age of 75 she unveiled new designs and
reopened house Chanel this sparked a
resurgence in the brand's popularity
Coco Chanel chose a man named Karl
Lagerfeld to be her successor for the
brand's she had more than enough money
to retire and live a comfortable life
but she worked until the day she died On
January the 10th 1971 when she died she
was 87 years old and had an estimated
net worth of a hundred million dollars
now this might sound like a lot of money
but do you keep in mind the Pierre
vitamins grandsons still owned 90
percent of Chanel even to this very day
they're now multi billionaires today
many people think of Chanel as a brand
that is intimidating and unattainable
but for those who look at the price tag
they missed the point Coco Chanel was
quoted saying on more than one occasion
that she believed people should wear
what makes them happy where the colors
you feel great in and the style that
makes you feel comfortable
instead of trying to be flashy or to
follow a trend your attitude and the way
you carry yourself
speaks far more than the clothes on your
back she said fashion is not something
that exists in dresses only fashion is
in the sky in the street fashion has to
do with ideas the way we live and what
is happening now - before in today's
video I just want to say that our
audience on biographic says only about
10% female and we often look at these
analytics when we decide what videos to
make if you're a woman in the audience
please do subscribe so we know you're
out there and if you feel inspired by
the story of Coco Chanel please share
this with someone in your life that you
know would appreciate it - and as always
thank you for watching
[Music]